hi there it's me ross matthews hi it's
ross matthews with rapidfire ross i'm
here with helen deltrey hilton carter
zoe francois lindsay karowski jenny yolo
i'm going to ask you questions that you
know really don't even deserve to be
asked but we're going to have fun
what is your worst baking fail
delivering a wedding cake the cake
collapse on the way to a wedding
and i still have like a physical
response whenever i think of it
what is the best dessert you've ever
tasted
so depending on my mood it's probably
devil's food cake covered in maybe a
coffee buttercream or and ice cream
cake and ice cream oh my god it's so
simple i feel like even this
conversation is off my diet what is one
tip to help people out there who just
want to try it okay okay so it's not an
entirely sexy answer but getting a
kitchen scale it like changes the entire
game because then everything is always
consistent it's actually less cleanup
and everything just comes out
better and one final question be honest
do you watch yourself on zoe bakes okay
i don't watch myself but my kids and my
dogs are often on the show and i do love
to see them on the show okay so yes i
watch it just be honest you watch
yourself who isn't watching you thank
you zoe
wow you're tall okay that's better
that's better i'm gonna ask you rapid
fire questions about house plants bring
it how do you keep one alive because i
can't do it well i would say love
patience
probably a bit of tenderness
you did say how do you keep a
relationship alive right no just plant
but thank you that's all good take away
for relationships or plants should i be
afraid of venus flight traps because i
saw a little shop of horrors and it
scarred me love little shopper horse one
of my favorite films unless you are a
fly i don't think you need to be afraid
they uh help remove some of those gnats
when people have gnats when they have
house plants they can remove those from
the environment in your home what is
your all-time favorite texas barbecue
pulled pork
mashed potatoes yes macaroni and cheese
okay okay adding up now it's a lot i'm a
big guy i understood jalapeno cornbread
what holla at me all right that's a cut
lunch
would you rather stay in a hotel or a
motel and what's the difference
great question motel all the way why
first of all i drive everywhere i drove
here it took me 20 hours to get here i'm
a driver i like to park the car in front
you know in los angeles it takes you 20
hours to get anywhere you know yeah i
live there and yes it does you're
correct because you are traveling around
as you're looking at different hotels
and motels what's a trend that needs to
go
oh this is a great question i hate a
popcorn ceiling i think everyone does oh
the carpet listen the carpet that has
the design in it so you can't see that
your kids like puked everywhere yeah
yeah that's terrible do carpet tile or
hardwood do you watch yourself
i'd like to be cool and say no but yes i
absolutely yes you absolutely do who
wouldn't
what's the number one tip for people who
are looking at that wall or that project
and thinking
paint really gotta use paint paint's
cheap it's easy uh you can fix it
relatively like with it's not like a ton
of commitment and you can grab a
paintbrush you can just start splotching
on some stuff and make some wallpaper
looking i do that in the workshop really
yeah what's the color right now that you
would recommend like the hot color at
the moment i mean dark colors like a
dark maroon a dark plum something like
that what's different about texas design
i mean we're here in waco do you bring
in sort of texas into your your diy and
your home decor i've done a little
shiplap in my houses but i like doing it
vertical to do a little bit different
than the texas style but
can you spell texas backwards well this
is like my nightmare from like middle
school uh spelling bee s-a-s-e-s-a-x
e.t
you got it you got it you got it thanks
so much everyone watch handcrafted home
projects jenny yolo on magnolia
let me ask you a question about flowers
carnations tacky or underrated love them
love them they last forever
come in all sorts of colors they get a
bad rap but they're they're one of my
faves so many times i get flowers and
then like i feel like a day later
they're already wilted so what can we do
to keep our flowers to last longer well
you know what you got to think about it
like would you want to be sat in
stagnant water change that water every
day give them a little snip maybe change
them if they're in direct light take
them out directly all right and what do
you do to keep it fresh on art in bloom
that's a good question i try and
challenge myself so we've changed it up
we're trying to do something different
for each episode give people new skill
sets to take away yeah not to put too
much pressure on yourself see i think
people bring so much pressure when
they're trying to make things beautiful
but it can be easy it can be fun and it
can be doable and you're showing us how
to do it thank you so much oh my gosh my
absolute pleasure